so on board the rss attenborough i can
hear you staying at home was that the
one that was called boaty mcboatface yes
it is more on that coming up in just a
short time before that though he
declared he'd build a stronger economy
for the british people in his budget
address but now economists warning the
chancellor's measures will leave the
poorest families far worse off the
government's own forecaster says the
cost of living could rise at its highest
level for 30 years i'll be asking rishi
tsunaki if his plans for nation's
finances add up in a moment but first
this report from our chief political
correspondent john craig
cheers boris johnson and rishi sunak
raised a glass to the chancellor's big
spending budget in which the tea total
mr sunak lowered the duty on draft beers
knocking 3p off a pint and cut the cost
of sparkling wines like champagne and
prosecco
the chancellor joked about draft relief
and beer barrel politics as he raised
the tax burden to its highest level
since the 1950s and public spending by
150 billion pounds to its highest since
the 70s
and in this brewery tap room in york
drinkers weren't exactly fizzing with
enthusiasm about the alcohol duty
overhaul either cheers people are going
to drink what they want to drink so um i
mean you know especially people that
come into bars like this
so these these sort of areas you know
these sort of bars are going to get hit
by it so it's not going to make a blind
bit of difference i'm not really a
massive drinker i don't drink an awful
lot so i don't think it'd really
bother me that much
back in westminster it's day two of the
commons debate on the spend now tax
later budget with the focus today on
business and the rising cost of living
after yesterday's cheers from
conservative back benchers and the
welcome for measures such as cheaper
beer and bubbly today's the day when the
budget could fall flat as the serious
scrutiny begins
a verdict on the chancellor's budget
will be delivered by the authoritative
institute for fiscal studies later
it's easy to be optimistic it seems to
be optimistic about the public finances
and and so on but the reality is that we
are still in a period of low growth
we're in a period of what looks like
high
um inflation and in particular in a
period of pretty
feeble growth if any
in living standards and so it's not
going to people aren't going to suddenly
feel much better off i'm afraid
but treasury ministers insist measures
like a tax change to let lower paid
workers keep more of their universal
credit
will make many people better off
what we're going to see as a result of
these changes if you're for example a a
single mum in a place like darlington
you're renting you've got two kids
you're going to be 1200 pounds a year
better off in december as a result of
the change to universal credit has just
been announced
the chancellor claims that despite his
spending spree he's on a mission to cut
taxes before the next election
but some mps fear turning on the taps
will lead to a budget hangover
john craig sky news
to god's own country of lancashire the
chancellor rishi sunak is there for us
now um good morning to you chancellor
let's start should we were john ended up
um are you going to cut good morning are
you going to cut taxes before the next
election let's just go with a yes or no
well we started cutting taxes yesterday
okay our priority being those on the
lowest incomes it's a tax cut for two
million families and it's not going to
come in until well it's not going to
come in as normal next april it's going
to come in a few weeks time so we can
get help to people right now but as i
said very clearly yesterday my ambition
is to lower taxes for people that's what
i would like to do as chancellor we had
to take some corrective action as a
result of the crisis and the response we
took to it but you know hopefully that
now is done and as we demonstrated
yesterday our priority is to make sure
that work pays we reward people's
efforts and i'm delighted that we could
make a start on that yesterday okay will
there be income tax cuts before the next
election go on go with yes or no
no no no okay we'll just let's talk
about this budget rather than all the
other ones
well this is what a lot of people have
been asking and certainly a lot of tory
back ventures want to know the answer to
that so asking for a friend
well they i i spend time with them
myself actually but look i think i i
made a very clear uh demonstration of
our intent yesterday and i think it's
important to remember why are we in this
position a year ago we outlined our plan
for jobs at a time when people think
well they feared the worst and because
of the plan that we put in place which
the independent forecaster yesterday
described as remarkably successful we've
managed to ensure that economic growth
is recovering the economy is growing
well many more people in work
unemployment is far lower than feared
and because of that yesterday we had a
budget that will deliver a stronger
economy for the british people so
stronger public services investment in
our future growth backing businesses
much like the ones i'm surrounded by
today but also supporting working
families like freezing fuel duty and
cutting taxes on the lowest paid but we
were able to do all of that because of
the action that we took last year
okay highest tax rate since the 1950s
inflation potentially up to five percent
interest rates potentially three and a
half percent you made no apology for any
of that that's all common knowledge uh
national insurance of course going up in
april as well
how much more will you personally be uh
paying with your national insurance do
you know
yeah well the the thing about national
insurance is it's a progressive tax and
it's been described as such by all of
the various commentators uh when it was
outlined but as you said that the tax
burden as i said yesterday i'm
uncomfortable with it where it is and
i'd like to see taxes come down on
people which is why we took a first step
on that yesterday and with a grant of
inflation that's absolutely right that's
one of the many challenges that i have
to grapple with as a chancellor i
explained yesterday to provide hopefully
some reassurance with the country that
the bulk of the inflation we're seeing
is the result of two global forces one
economy's reopening and supply chains
being uh under pressure and secondly
energy prices now i don't have a magic
wand and it would be irresponsible of me
to stand here and tell you i could make
those global problems disappear
overnight i can't but where the
government can take action to help with
the cost of living whether it's through
things like freezing fuel duty or
cutting taxes for the lowest paid or
indeed things like investing in lorry
park facilities which the transport
secretary announced yesterday to help
attract people into that profession
where we can make a difference of course
we will
okay back to the question um we've made
a calculation that your national
insurance will be eight and a half
thousand pounds uh given your salary of
148 thousand pounds as the as the
chancellor um you know given that you
earn a good salary and given that you
did very well in the city and you know
you have um you you're very comfortably
off do you feel that that is enough of a
contribution by you
[Music]
i think national insurance is a
progressive way to raise money the top
14
of income earners on national insurance
end up contributing over half of all the
sums raised from that uh tax rise so i
think actually it is a progressive way
to raise money those with the broadest
shoulders will carry more of the burden
and it's important to remember what was
that for that was money for the nhs our
number one priority to help the nhs
recover and make a start on tackling the
the significant backlogs that have built
up during the crisis and to implement
the prime minister's landmark reforms to
social care something that okay any
other governments have not been able to
achieve so that that's what that one is
therefore there's no easy way to raise
tax there's no perfect way to do it it's
it's not my question though chancellor
you know
the question is is there a better one
but it's you know it's always vulgar if
you think that's something
of course
i can talk money with the chancellor can
i not if i can't talk money with the
chancellor then who can i you're worth
tens of millions of pounds
if you are paying eight and a half
thousand pounds in national insurance
and you've got a very very healthy bank
balance do you think that is fair do you
think that is leveling up
i think i think what leveling up is is
i'm standing here in the world famous
berry market which yesterday received 20
million pounds from our leveling up fund
to improve the market create new jobs
and ensure that places like berry c
investment that's leveling up in
practice making sure people's
communities are fantastic places to live
leveling up is about spreading
opportunity around the country making
sure that wherever people are they have
the skills the opportunities to train
but those are the kinds of things that
leveling up means and with regard to
making sure that we help everyone
yesterday we cut taxes for two million
of the lowest paid people in the country
so that is a very clear statement of
both my values the government's values
and our desire to help those who
absolutely need our help the most so i'm
going to take that as yes you think
eight and a half grand is enough on your
salary and wealth at the ifs though
given what you've just been saying they
say living standards will stagnate for
people who've had a really hard time and
that's because of the higher taxes from
what you're saying you disagree with the
ifs
well i think i'd look at the measures
that we put in place as we've just
talked about a tax cut for two million
of the lowest pay people in our country
and i think your report was showing so a
single mother with two kids who's
renting will be better off by about 1
200 pounds a year a couple where someone
is working full time and someone is
working part-time on the national living
wage with two kids renting will be 1 800
pounds a year better off the national
living wage went up yesterday to 9
pounds 50 and that will mean a thousand
pounds more for someone who's working
full-time on the national living wage so
there are lots of things we are doing
that will help people keep more of their
money ensure that they can earn more and
keep the cost of living down for example
the ifs says that living standards will
stagnate do you disagree
well actually coming into this crisis
other think tanks said we were enjoying
a mini living standards boom and real
household disposable income was
increasing at a reasonably rapid rate
and people will look at the measures
that we've announced whether it's
freezing fuel duty cutting taxes for
millions of the lowest paid
the national living wage going up all
the investment we're putting into
people's skills to make sure that they
can get retraining or learn new things
that will help them earn more those are
all the types of things we can do to
raise living standards and i'm confident
that over the next few months and years
just as we have over the last 12 months
seen success in our economic plans we
will continue to see that success going
forward okay let me ask you about the
climate then instead
fuel duty
frozen again uh air passenger duty
reduced for uh national
travel um do you not care about the
environment
oh hang on kay just a minute ago you're
asking me about living standards for
people and the cost of living and and
now you're upset that we're freezing
fuel duty or making it cheaper on
what i'm doing is asking you whether you
don't care about fuel prices
yeah well well
we just talked about this and with fuel
prices at almost a decade high i didn't
think it was the right thing to do to
add to people's costs by increasing fuel
duty and with regard to air passenger
duty i think what you didn't mention is
we also are introducing a new band for
ultra long-haul flights so that those
who fly the furthest to places like
japan or chile will see a higher rate of
air passenger duty not much of a higher
rate to be fair
not much of a higher rate and at the
same time well actually if you look at
if you look at the impact on carbon the
the overall uh i think view from the
independent forecast yesterday was taken
in totality with the measures that we
are taking put us further along the path
to net zero and reduce climate
initiatives okay and that's just one of
the things we're doing we're also
investing money in creating what are
called sustainable aviation fuel plants
in the uk and passion of the prime
ministers to find you know a new form of
aviation fuel that's more sustainable
that was all outlined last week in the
net zero strategy and it's important to
remember that aviation in general
accounts for i think just about eight
percent of our emissions and uh the
domestic bit of that which you referred
to at the beginning is about four
percent of the eight percent so this
this is a small amount
okay your your opposite number uh rachel
reeves saying at least bankers and short
haul uh flights on short haul flights so
we'll be cheering with champagne um so
that's their view on that i'll put it to
uh in the next hour i suppose cop is all
about action though isn't it not in 2050
but now so why are you uh instead
benefiting motorists and people who are
on short haul flights rather than
worrying about emissions
well i we do worry about missions and
that's why last week we outlined a
comprehensive net zero strategy the
prime minister put that out there it's i
think widely been considered one of the
most comprehensive plans of any
government anywhere in the world it was
backed up with 30 billion pounds of
investment across the board in areas
like offshore wind nuclear hydrogen
carbon capture and storage the
electrification of our car fleet uh as
you as you rightly mentioned all those
things are covered in it so we're very
clearly incredibly on a path to net zero
but i just pick up on one thing i think
you said my labour opposite number was
upset that we were going to cut the duty
on sparkling wine and champagne i'm not
going to make any apologies for that we
have an irrational system at the moment
of how we tax alcohol the new system
we're going to bring in into place it's
going to be simpler it's going to be
fairer and it's going to be healthier
and it's going to support pubs and i
know many people enjoy whether it's a
prosecco to celebrate something we've
seen sparkling wine sales in the country
double in just the last five years
fueled by actually bottles of prosecco
that may cost seven pounds or so and the
price of those bottles will come down by
about 87 p and i think that's a good
thing actually because everyone when
something good happens wants to
celebrate uh with a bit of bubbly and
we're actually going to remove the
completely irrational duty premium that
those drinks currently bear they're no
more alcoholic than still wine but yet
they pay a lot more duty that seems to
me to be unfair and silly and i'd like
to be able to sort that out
celebrating with champagne maybe not
those that are struggling to feed their
kids but that's that's perhaps for
another day uh carbon emissions is that
the best place for you to be this
morning well actually
on that point
if i could ask the question because
we're almost out of time you are at a
meat market today why are you in a meat
market when we're told to eat less meat
to try and cut down on carbon emissions
i i i mean i i'm not telling anyone uh
to eat less meat and and you mentioned
children actually yesterday's budget
confirmed 200 million pounds a year for
the holiday activity and food program
which is a new program that this
government has introduced to provide
enriching activities and meals for
children outside of term time that was
something the spending review yesterday
confirmed as well as actually lots of
investment to help young families and
especially new parents
who are struggling with various things
because it's something that we believe
is important
those early days in children's lives and
young parents lives are really important
and as a result of the actions we took
yesterday we're going to be able to do
more to support them which i think is
you're not you're not telling people to
eat less meat but your chief scientific
advisor is to try and cut down on carbon
emissions
there's lots of different ways that we
can tackle climate change and last week
the prime minister outlined the net zero
strategy i don't think there was
anything about that in there but what
there was was the green industrial
revolution as he would describe it with
investment to catalyze the industries of
the future to help us make the
transition and the process create lots
of jobs and and that's exactly what
we're trying to do i like to think i
made it took a small role in you finally
getting your dog how is the dog
yes yes yes you did the dog she's she's
great thank you growing quickly and uh
and a handful so but she'll start
needing some proper runs soon so you
might see me out about and the kids are
thrilled i'm guessing she's good i'm
looking forward to spending yeah they
are they are thrilled doing more to help
finally which is also good and i'm
looking forward to actually spending a
bit more time with her now that i've got
this budget out of the way
fantastic we'll see you at cop26 next
week thanks a lot chancellor
see you next week okay thank you thank
you
let's have a look at the impact of
climate change on the planet should we
talking about that with the chancellor
top line shows how the uk's power is
produced here we go
and you can see how much warmer the
earth is now than in 1880 row two
then the figure to how long scientists
believe it will take to reach the plus
1.5 degrees celsius figure seen by many
as a point of no return for the planet
row 3 and finally the total amount of
co2 emissions in millions of tons
still to come just after half past seven
we'll be joined by the founder of the
big issue magazine that's lord john bird
as he warns the uk is about to see a
mass homelessness crisis
after eight o'clock we'll get more
reaction to the budget with the shadow
chancellor rachel reeves
will be joined by the royal british
legion and one of their youngest
fundraisers as this year's poppy appeal
gets underway
[Music]
starts today wearing your poppy with
pride the government's chief scientist
says we will all need to change our
behavior including eating less meat
chancellor doesn't agree and flying less
often chancellor doesn't agree to help
tackle climate change just days before
the cop 26 summit in glasgow sir patrick
valance has joined with scientists from
around the world and called on world
leaders to take urgent action they say
it's only possible to curb temperature
rises by drastic reductions in global
emissions within a decade speaking to
sir patrick at half a state on the
program
put some of the things that the
chancellor said to him at that time also
the president of cop 26 summit alex
sharma has echoed the prime minister's
cautious tone about the conference
saying that hopes that a deal on global
warming can be reached are in the
balance he's been speaking to our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter
so
just days from the cop 26 u.n climate
summit in glasgow we meet the event's
president alok sharma in downing street
there's a long shopping list of problems
that need to be sorted out china needs
to commit to more there needs to be an
agreement on phasing out coal it looks
like cop 26
is in real trouble
look you're absolutely right i mean this
is going to be difficult this is going
to be a big big challenge this is
getting almost 200 countries to reach
consensus on some of these difficult
issues that have been outstanding for
six years now it is in the balance
adding to the strain the un has just
issued a dire warning that the world is
way off track in limiting temperature
rises to a safe threshold
the united nations secretary general
said that the issue was a leadership gap
is it a problem with your leadership
my job as cop 26th president is
effectively to act as shepherd in chief
but ultimately this does come down
to world leaders delivering on their
commitments uh you know i i can't force
any one country to do anything
that definitely applies to china it has
already committed to peak emissions by
2030 and net zero by 2060 but global
targets will be missed if the world's
largest polluter isn't more ambitious
we are still waiting
for china to come forward with its 2030
mission reduction target i had a meeting
yesterday with the chinese delegation
and what did they tell you are they
going to move and i made the same ask
again
and i repeated that they along with
every g20 nation has promised before cop
26 four days from now to come forward
with that commitment are you confident
that they will come forward with
enhanced targets i very much hope they
along with every other g20 country that
has not yet come forward will do so it
is china that matters though above all
do you accept that well absolutely china
china is the biggest emitter china
matters uh but you know
so they are the biggest emitter by that
by that very statement so if they don't
move cop is in jeopardy
just about all the g20 17 out of the 20
have said that they're going to um go to
net zero by the middle of the century
that is a move but of course that's
that's not enough what keeps me up at
night is uh just yeah thinking about the
complexity of this what we want is for
us to win for the world to collectively
win so that we can say to you know our
generation but also the future
generations that we delivered when it
mattered
that's the ambition
geopolitics may get in the way
in a few days time we'll find out
hannah thomas peter sky news in downing
street
the latest british research ship to
study the effects of climate change is
due to set sail from london in the next
few days aisha zaheed is on the rrs sir
david attenborough and she is with us
now hi what's it like good morning
good morning k yeah the ris sir david
attenborough will be heading off on its
first mission next month but first it's
in greenwich for the next three days for
several reasons first of all so the
public can have a look they won't be
able to get on board but they can
definitely come down to see it
and also to mark the start of cop26 in a
matter of a few days we'll see world
leaders flocking to glasgow for that
climate change summit and senior
scientific advisors are also using the
ship as a platform
to issue an important statement to
address the urgent need for action to be
taken against climate change we'll hear
from sir patrick balance later today uh
on uh him calling for world leaders to
take action to curb temperature rises to
1.5 degrees celsius and he'll also be
calling for uh world leaders to come
together to uh to address the negative
effects global warming could have if
action isn't taken taken the ris will be
heading off uh in a matter of days next
month it will be embarking on its
mission in the antarctic to see just how
devastating the effects of global
warming are there and to understand
climate change better
thai sure looks beautiful there doesn't
it and as leaders arrive in glasgow from
around the world we'll have special
coverage of the cop 26 u.n climate
summit from 5 p.m on sunday night on sky
news
and for uninterrupted coverage of the
summer including special guests and
analysis you can watch sky news climate
live on channel 525 from 10 a.m on
monday also making the news for you this
morning a british fishing boat has been
detained by french authorities this
morning it comes just hours after
officials in paris said they'd block
british vessels from french ports and
restrict energy supplies to the channel
islands unless a deal for licenses to
fish in the channel can be agreed
the united states has issued its first
ever passport with a new gender category
the x designation is for people who
don't identify as either male or female
donna zim is an intersex campaigner from
colorado who claims to be the first
individual to receive the new document
more than one million uk households may
have fallen victim to a scam known as
brushing after receiving mystery amazon
parcels they didn't order
amazon says not many orders are affected
and it has robust processes in place to
stop this kind of abuse
there has been flooding in parts of
glasgow with a warning of further
torrential rain to come meanwhile much
of cumbria remains on an amber warning
with forecasters saying nearly 10 inches
of rain could fall there
sadia choudry is in kendall in cumbria
for us this morning we are cycling up
there in 10 days or so hopefully it's
going to get a bit better by then
hopefully it will but for the next 24
hours or so parts of scotland and here
in cumbria the met office's
warning of life-threatening flooding as
a month's worth of rain is set to fall
in these areas now in scotland there are
17 flood warnings already and here in
cumbria look at this
part of town usually
is expected to get about 160 millimeters
of rain in the month of october but the
met office is warning that that is set
to rise to 300 millimeters so that's
nearly doubling and the cumbria fire and
service
service has tweeted to say that people
need to be alert to the dangers of flood
water um i'll read out this tweet from
that you from them they said
never enter flood water on foot or in a
vehicle and call 999 if life is at risk
we're here to help that's a tweet from
the cumbria fire and rescue service
travel is also set to be disrupted with
avanti uh train services saying they've
had to cancel many of their services uh
north of preston
okay thank you thanks a lot
quick look at the weather for you know
next few days as we're hearing mild and
windy rain over some central and western
parts bringing localized floodings just
heard that didn't we
and
those are the weather warnings in place
now of all the things to disrupt a round
of golf you might expect a stray dog or
a fox walking across the course but
you've probably never seen this
before here we go amateur australian
golfer wendy powick was teeing off on
the gold coast when she faced
how's this for golf today an invasion of
kangaroos
she posted the pictures on social media
never seen this happen before she said
they decided to charge
right up the fairway the official name
for a group of kangaroos is
called
a mob
and they were not having
any of it weren't they
great pictures
in a few minutes we'll talk to lord bird
founder of the big issue magazine as he
warns the uk is about to see a mass
homelessness crisis
[Music]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're probably firing again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
[Music]
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along all the way we take
you to the heart of the stories that
shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Applause]
the chancellor has this morning rejected
criticism that his budget plans will
leave many families worse off the
institute for fiscal studies warned
increases in tax would lead to an almost
non-existent increase in living
standards short time ago rishi sunak
said raising taxes was the fairest way
to pay off the public debt the thing
about national insurance is it's a
progressive tax and it's been described
as such by all of the various
commentators uh when it was outlined but
as you said the tax burden as i said
yesterday i'm uncomfortable with it
where it is and i'd like to see taxes
come down on people which is why we took
a first step on that yesterday now i
don't have a magic wand and it would be
irresponsible of me to stand here and
tell you i can make those global
problems disappear overnight i can't but
where the government can take action to
help with the cost of living whether
it's through things like freezing fuel
duty or cutting taxes for the lowest
paid or indeed things like investing in
lorry park facilities which the
transport secretary announced yesterday
to help attract people into that
profession where we can make a
difference of course we will
tamara's here those with the broadest
shoulders should uh shoulder the biggest
burden the ifes saying something
completely different that's right rishi
seanac told you he's comfortable where
the tax burden is right now it will
after the changes he announced yesterday
be it the highest level since the 1950s
and that will help him fund some of this
big spending spree increases for all
government departments we seem to be a
long way from the david cameron george
osborne era of austerity but the reason
that some conservatives may not be very
comfortable about it is they had not
expected our big reset after covid to be
a bigger state and higher taxes but also
is it going to actually help those on
the lowest incomes rishi cenac said that
he started cutting taxes yesterday and
what he means by that is that people on
universal credit on benefits who are in
work will keep more of what they earn
more than we expected so they're going
to be better off those who are not in
work or can't find work will not be
better off and the criticism is that
while he says people on the national
living wage will see their incomes go up
they'll be feeling better off the
institute for fiscal study said hang on
inflation's going to hit four or five
percent next year we've got rising taxes
we've got the prospect of rising energy
bills as well all that might wipe it out
so you're looking actually not just next
year but in the next few years at
livingston is really stagnating and not
going up very much at all
chancellor didn't accept that although
he didn't he said that global he talked
a lot about global forces that we can't
control but that will be the acid test
of course do people feel better off as a
result of all this spending and if they
don't i think the jitters will deepen in
the conservative party about whether it
has really made a difference
he was trying to convince me also that
he was a green chancellor that's right
of course we've got the cop summit which
is the climate change summit in glasgow
starting this weekend the whole point of
it is all about delivering measures
which right now reduce emissions given
the un says it's very urgent
he has frozen duty on petrol diesel
yesterday now the chancellor points out
that one people struggle with living
standards he wants to help them out he
doesn't want people who are really
reliant on their cars to be paying more
for petrol and you can see that living
standards argument but it does jar a bit
with the
climate change argument because that is
the biggest green tax the chancellor has
in his armoury and we saw that frozen we
saw air passenger duty on short haul
flights cut a bit so i think cut in half
and so i think we saw some voices in in
parliament yesterday including caroline
lucas saying
the green mp saying this is not in line
with what we're supposed to be achieving
at cop the chancellor says look we've
announced this huge plan to decarbonize
the economy but that is taking us to
2050 and of course the measures that
happen now uh do really matter
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it thank you meantime the
founder of the big issue magazine is
calling on the government to take urgent
action to prevent a big rise in levels
of homelessness lord john bird will tell
parliament the reduction in universal
credit and the end of furlough has put
thousands of people at risk of losing
their home uh lord bird is with us now
hello t lord bird um i hear what you're
saying i've just been chatting to the
chancellor he completely disagrees he's
saying he's doing what he can to help as
many people as possible especially those
on low or no incomes
well i mean he's he's making gestures
which obviously every chancellor has to
do
65 million
for paying people's rent arrears
when the combined amount is probably
nearest
360 million is a bit like taking a fire
extinguisher to a forest fire you can
see that it's a good gesture maybe he
will find more money later on but we've
got this real problem and that is that
with half a million people behind in
their rents
and mortgages and you've got this
situation where more and more people are
going to be evicted then you could have
thousands and thousands if not hundreds
of thousands of people who were brought
into homelessness for the first time
at the same time of course you've got to
deal with the problem of people already
homeless so you've got the people
already homeless then you've got the
people who could become homeless and if
the government actually recognized that
it is still in the middle of the
emergency
rather than
well into the recovery then we would
carry on the emergency until we got into
the recovery which obviously means
borrowing more money but there's only
one way of getting out of this and that
is investing in keeping people in their
homes and supporting them
they're topping up the the universal
credit the universal credit top up was
what um uh osborne removed
you know what in the days of the in the
days of the um
of the austerity
sorry
no no not at all i just wanted to go on
to ask you whether when it comes to
homelessness is it or is it all about
funding
or are there other issues that you'll be
highlighting to the government today
that they should also be thinking about
well i mean the
the unfortunate thing about
cutting the the universal credit is
the pop-up is
a big problem
the fact that people's uh
cost of heating and food gone up the
fact that actually people will probably
do they do they or do they not
pay their rent or do they feed the
family or do they turn on the point and
these are
actually not being addressed and need to
be addressed
okay um
i know am i right in saying
we spoke obviously we speak regularly
but we spoke a few months ago about um
the big issue uh sellers and the and
they've now been
been able to go back out onto the
streets to to sell their words for the
first time since the pandemic and how
has that been
well it
well i mean the problem is that most big
issue vendors are not selling the amount
of papers because there's not that
amount of people on the streets
and also people are being more wary
about the money that they're spending
but overall we've had a really good
return and we've had great support from
the public we've had we've had great
support in the in the 2020 period of
last year of the coving we we had
support from the government uh because
we got the bounce-back loan so there's
we're in a good position but if we have
another recession
brought on by a lot then we really are
going to be up against it and what we're
doing with our vendors we're doing
everything possible to make sure that
they are prepared
hopefully for a very very good christmas
but we have to look beyond that what's
going to happen in the new year and that
is why the the budget which is a great
indication of where we're going is not
really addressing all of those basic
industry
incidents that everybody has to handle
in the in the coming period
okay lord bird it's always a pleasure to
talk to you thank you for joining us on
the program thank you
british fishing boat has been detained
by french authorities this morning it
comes just hours after officials in
paris say they'll block british vessels
from french ports and restrict energy
supplies to the channel islands unless a
deal for licenses to fish in the channel
can be agreed well our europe grows one
adam parsons is in brussels for us
what's going on adam good morning
yeah significant diplomatic row uh
started over the past few days now seems
to be escalating overnight a british
fishing boat uh where two were spoken to
but one of them seems to have been
detained in the port of la have on the
basis that it doesn't have the correct
license
and today
in the past few minutes actually the
french minister for
maritime
and the french europe minister have both
been on the airwaves putting forward
france's case and both of them have been
frankly quite belligerent clinton burned
europe minister
saying that france will now have to use
strength because that's effectively the
only thing that the uk understands uh
and uh the french maritime minister
anika gerhardin
saying that uh
that the france has to be combative she
says this is combat it's not a war
and also saying that the strong measures
will involve most british vessels being
banned from french ports now these
measures are due to come in on the 2nd
of november and significant progress
hasn't been made in issuing licenses
to french fishermen she says they've
been nine months of waiting it's
unacceptable they are defending their
fishermen british government says it's
granted 98 of licenses already to eu
vessels the french have responded today
and say that isn't true the figure is
just over 90 and they say the missing 10
is they in their opinion all french
fishermen effectively on the one hand
this looks like a fairly small dispute
over what is a relatively small number
of vessels but the other thing is this
is about fishing which is totemically
important to both the uk and france and
it happens at a time of tension already
caused by the rouse over the northern
ireland protocol this might look like
it's just a small row about fishing it
does have the potential to go
explosively large if british boats are
banned from french ports that is going
to seem like a big move and remember
britain has said it reserves the right
to take its own reciprocal measures it
says this is a disproportionate act
you know relations between britain and
france weren't great over the course of
the past year they are deteriorating
before our eyes okay thank you thanks
adam
duchess of cornwall has joined in the
debate about how to prevent sexual
violence against women in a speech last
night she urged men and women to end the
culture where physical abuse is seen as
normal a warning that this report from
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
contains flash photography
they're two women who know every word
they say will be picked apart the
duchess of cornwall and carrie johnson
coming together to take a stand against
sexual violence
camilla using the opportunity to deliver
the most powerful speech of her royal
life
on average
one woman is killed by a man every three
days
sarah everard
sabina messer
wenjing lin
names which
with all the others
must never be forgotten
we do not in any way hold all men
responsible for sexual violence
but we do need them all aboard to tackle
it
after all rapists are not born they're
constructed
and it takes an entire community male
and female to dismantle the lies words
and actions that foster
culture in which sexual assault is seen
as normal and in which it shames the
victim
camilla has talked about the issues of
rape and domestic violence for a number
of years now but what seems to have
changed is in the past there was maybe a
nervousness about what she said in
public now there's a clear determination
to do whatever she can to make a
difference
for the prime minister's wife it also
could not be more personal as a student
she was drugged by the taxi rapist john
warboys
the shameless festival against sexual
violence takes place in london next
month in camilla they have a powerful
advocate ready to reinforce the message
that enough is enough
rhiannon mills sky news in central
london
students are boycotting nightclubs after
more than 50 females reported they had
been spiked with a needle we'll talk to
the nighttime industries association
next
[Music]
um we want to be the first distiller on
the island of isla to go net zero on
carbon emissions
um traditionally uh stills are fed with
steam that's generated from fossil fuels
we are going to stop that and we're
going to stop it in in early early next
year by installation of a
a biomass boiler what it does is it
takes a by-product from our system
called giraffe and we mix that with with
wood from local forests which would
otherwise not be used for for commercial
use
and um it's a it's a scheme it's a plant
that is funded by amp um
energy and
also so they will they have installed it
for us uh their contractor is a company
called dalal they will run it and we
will buy the steam back from them so
effectively kay what we're doing is
we're going net zero on carbon emissions
on the island yeah
and so really you know to become net
zero is is really quite an achievement
and we'll we will we will we will
achieve it next year so it's um yeah we
will what we want to do is really set an
example for the rest of the industry
we're not the first um distiller to do
but we're the first on either um and the
fact is we came up with this idea myself
and my team just over a year ago because
because we can we don't need to wait
until until 2040 when the scottish
whiskey association has set the date for
growing carbon in neutral we can do an
eye and we think we should
we're in it for the long term really and
our customers you know are going to be
customers in in that in in that time 12
years 20 years and this is going to mean
much much more to them and i i hope they
will thank us for doing this now because
you know to take this this step because
actually we're not saving any money
doing this and we're doing it because
it's the right thing and and our leaders
in buena haven have supported us
entirely in doing this
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
there'll be a mild windy start with rain
from cornwall up into southern scotland
and heavy showers to the west northern
england will stay wet through the
morning and wales in southwest england
will turn wet but southern scotland will
largely dry up elsewhere it'll be mostly
fine but the north-western scotland can
expect heavy showers
it'll stay very mild scotland will see
showers clearing later there'll be
little change elsewhere the unsettled
conditions mean air pollution levels
should remain low with levels between 1
and three on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
students across the country being urged
to join a boycott of nightclubs after
more than 200 incidents the so-called
spiking were reported to the police
sky news has learned that officers have
also received 56 cases of spiking by
injection let's speak to the chief exec
of the night time industries association
that's michael kill hello to you thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning how big a problem is this
well it's a big problem that's been
running for um several decades um and
the nightlife industry has been fighting
it um very very hard with many many
mitigations but
in light of the recent reports and the
levels that are coming forward it's it's
levied some huge concern for us as an
industry and you know we we've had to
step up and and really work very hard
with local authorities and police to to
put further mitigations and and lift our
level of searching training etc to
ensure that we are safeguarding people
coming into our settings
do you support the girls night in
boycott
i i believe without a doubt i i think
it's been fantastic that the girls have
stepped forward and brought this to
prominence um we have been speaking with
the organizers and and they're very
constructive and very clear with what
they they see that they would like to to
experience when they come into the
settings and we're working very closely
with them alongside the police and local
communities so absolutely i think it's
vitally important this is highlighted
and we have been calling for the home
office to do an inquiry
so that we can really understand the
breadth of the problem and start to
understand the characteristics around
these crimes so that we can tackle them
head on as communities as industries and
as authorities
i've seen um pictures recently of people
being searched as they go into nighttime
venues do you feel that there are
effective measures that are satisfactory
in place
i think we have some challenges and as
you've quite rightly alluded to
searching um we've only got limited
powers we haven't got the powers of the
police um we've gone back over to our
searching policies and and made sure
that we're very thorough as people walk
in to our premise but um you know we
have to have permission and many venues
up and down the country if people are
refusing searching they're not allowed
into the premise so we've been pretty
robust with our position and and i think
there are lots of other things that
we're doing at the moment including
training awareness campaigns uh
communication
enhance medical provision and so there's
lots of work that's going on at the
moment in the background and has been
launched last week but there's more to
do and i do believe that there is a
collective response to this because
there are wider societal issues not just
nightclubs that have these incidents
happening within those settings
um you say it's been going on for
decades though so why why are we still
in this position one wonders
well the the what was normally happening
with these instances they were sort of
coming as an ebb and flow so we were
seeing some of them come up at periods
like the uh freshers or student return
and they were they were very limited or
isolated incidents that were being
reported and being dealt with by the
police so
from the perspective of the industry we
were dealing with them head-on what's
happened now is there has been a very
clear
lift in reports people coming forward
whether it's happened to them recently
or whether it's happened to them in the
past and highlighting the challenges
around this and the worry around
normalization so we need to attack this
head-on i think it's a community
industry and
authorities position that need to be
undertaken undertaken and one of the
biggest concerns we have is the message
around conviction because at the moment
the conviction rates are very very poor
on this
um i'm guessing cctv would play a big
role in trying to sort that out but if
someone has been spiked or fear a friend
has been spiked either with an injection
or their drink directly what should they
do
i think it's important if it happens in
the settings like nightclubs bars etc
they must inform a member of staff if if
a member of the public sees someone
vulnerable they must inform a member of
staff all of our staff across the
country all of our members in the wider
industry are very proactive in terms of
ensuring people's welfare so it's really
important that you step forward and take
an active view on vulnerability
particularly people that are compromised
our staff are going through a regime of
training at the moment but i think it's
important that our community the people
that come to our venues take an active
part as well and we will give them the
relevant medical support and also inform
the police at the point that we believe
a crime has been committed but every one
of these are being taken seriously and
and this has been reinforced not only by
police but by the industry as a whole
and many industry leaders are leading on
this as well
okay michael good to talk to you thanks
for joining us on the program thank you
thank you
the chancellor saying his budget will
make working families better off despite
a warning from senior economists there
will be
no significant increase in living
standards we're going to have more on
that coming up in the next hour when we
spoke to the chancellor he was saying
that he was comfortable with the level
of tax that he was paying you can see
these images of him yesterday with the
prime minister remembering of course
that he doesn't drink but he said that
you know if people wanted to celebrate
with a glass of champagne or prosecco
from time to time it was right that they
didn't have to pay as much uh for that
going forward the institute for fiscal
studies has got a very different view on
what the chancellor has been saying they
think that people
are certainly wages are going to
stagnate over the next five years we'll
have more on that coming up here on sky
news also speaking to rachel reeves for
the opposition what does she think about
the measures introduced yesterday
[Music]